[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody welcome I'm John Luke
this is hey what's up
we're playing destiny well takes playing
down yes
not yet not yet um so yeah we're pretty
much checking out the new iron banner
well it's not new iron banner but like
mayhem is an iron banner for the first
time so I'm expecting like a lot of
crazy supers etc but also we're just
here to kind of talk about the fact that
we will both be going to check out
destiny to get about a little less than
a week yeah or so next Thursday
yep so just a little thing he has a
little invite little invite so just
tells you the info yeah 18th that's when
they're gonna do their gameplay reveal
stream as well it also came with this
wow he doesn't stay in the his his stand
Kade you we got this cool little
figurine which you get from the games
stop exclusive so no couple friends of
mine got that oh yeah
it's a lot bigger than I thought it
would be and it's pretty sturdy sturdy
vinyl up you're not bad he doesn't stay
in the and then the other thing we got
was the kind of like the dark ghost I
don't know if you guys can see that but
it's supposed to be like a world without
light you know yeah that's what it says
on this thing we'll have to see what
that means exactly but the pin is kind
of cool too I know you're a big pin guy
I'm not a not always big yeah I like
pins but I don't like it
I've become the pin guy in the office
and I'm not that into bins to level I
think people think I'm erina but I mean
compared to everyone else I guess you
could you could argue I have the most
pins at least yes at least every couple
of weeks I'll find someone is just like
put a pin on my desk oh I'll just walk
in my desk and there's a pin there I'm
like well that seems pretty good I mean
yeah I guess it's like not a bad a sure
she's like alright got a free pin yeah
when was the last time you played Esme
oh boy
the first iron banner they did after
that's about right yeah all right uh
maybe a little
I did the raid I into it on the hard
though juvie I am Lourdes yeah it's
about it
fair enough um oh it's a bad idea I
might have popped in for a winter event
or something for like a second those hot
events yeah I haven't pv peed in a long
time so this could go either horribly
well or terribly bad video how you look
at oh yeah it's mayhem - so like you
could chuck your needs and all that
stuff I like that gun you got yeah it's
the my toe with the Arctic skin right
they added skins got one alright
we are also checking out YouTube and the
twitch chat so if you guys are in there
playing destiny still have questions and
whatnot please feel free to ask me and
John Luke hopefully we can get you some
answers Oh a bubbled smart guy
now this point is very curious I'm just
I'm just excited to see what destiny jr.
has to offer
yeah we know that these three classes
are still in there not sure if there's
any different subclasses that'll be a si
no fourth class and now strength yeah
that's not yet at least
yeah hoping to see something can't you
see what they do with the story that was
um I think the lore of Destiny is
interesting um but not presented well in
the game like when you read those like
grimoire cards they have which first off
you have to go to a website or download
an app to read them right huh yeah like
that suck I was Aaron's thing he loved
the grimoire see yeah I think a lot of
people did to be honest like the writing
in those cards is actually pretty good
you know this is actually like kind of
some interesting sci-fi mm-hmm but it's
just not presented in a way that's like
good game you're like right it's like
put this in the game or like don't put
it large even if they actually put the
grimoire cards in the game I would still
still not enough like I want actual good
narrative so that's something I'm really
hoping destiny to
please forward a lot think I'm we've
already kind of started to go that
direction was like taking King and the
iron Lords that stuff was like more
story heavy than the original yeah
taking King stuff was good though I like
and I think they realize that so they're
definitely involving ke dwara as we saw
in the in the kind of like the trailer
and whatnot Jesus but yeah thank you
guys for the people that also tune in to
our stream earlier four forts have been
and Miguel did a great job so shout out
to those guys oh I just missed oh yeah
oh this is awkward
no how come has killed me and mine
didn't kill him so wants to know we
think of prey uh I'd be even playing oh
I'd be I'd be yesterday I loved it
personally seems to be a lot of mixed
reception around the office uh I know
mean Mike I seem to be on the like
absolutely like Lovett camp
um you know Jake's he's been doing it
yeah yeah it'll be I think that games
gonna just have like a overall mixed bag
yeah general I mean I think I want to
say our review hopefully should be up in
a couple days or so that's the idea yeah
review in progress is up Tamar's playing
that and from the UK so interesting to
see what he thinks I think he just beat
it okay I want to say I could be wrong
but yeah we should have that pretty soon
this is not going so hot I keep
forgetting that it's like mayhem and
right I should just be spamming the [ __ ]
out of my soup but you know I like using
my gun hello
so wants to know is this where you sign
up for the Destiny scrub League
yes all of this groves like that so you
look at how many hammers I just missed
no problem though
not punished I don't want to go over
there
so of all the things for Destin like
what do you want to see out of destined
to like what's the aspect you would be
looking for mmm
I mean I'm always a big fan of the raids
I've been were in the PvE than PvP and I
feel like they did a really good job
with Volta class um and I want to see
more of that I mean the raids after that
were like Oryx was fine um it was pretty
good
the rise of iron 1 was okay I feel like
yeah it wasn't like great but it wasn't
like bad like Kruger was bad
yeah koto is just not good we don't talk
about Koda I like crota aesthetically I
like that one actually playing it what
the [ __ ] okay always that's kind of the
one thing is that they never were able
to like top that original Raiden mm-hmm
for a lot of people so I'm just kind of
I mean they've been working on this one
for a while right yeah that's the idea
the good news though is that like Luke
Smith has a pretty big hand on destiny
too and he was the one that helped us do
you know the vaults as well as like
taking Kings though so I have high
pretty high hopes or like you know
higher hopes okay
hello but yeah I think a good
singleplayer a good singleplayer would
be it's pretty key
I definitely yeah because the PvP is
fine I don't think like anyone's like
this is an eSport or anything I think
trials of osiris is like a fun mode but
definitely not for everyone Jesus yeah I
don't really know what you would change
much about PvP Billy can kind of stay
the way it is and people will be pretty
okay with that yeah um and hopefully
yeah some people talk about the DLC and
hoping that there's not too much like
separated content but you know they're
obviously going to have their DLCs yeah
I mean they've already announced that
they're going to have to expansion and
expansion that
it reminds me of the blue juked the
smaller expansions you know the the
crota and with the dark below and the
house of wolves one it kind of the same
thing which I didn't like those because
they were much smaller so you like when
you got it you're like okay cool I
played it in a day
I'm kind of done mm-hmm and that's why I
really like taken King just taken King
you could you could be like the story
part in like a day but then there were
all those like really who were kidding
me yeah like the month it took me like
probably a good month to fully do
everything in that yeah I mean like just
getting all the calcified fragments and
then having a wait for those yeah it
took a long time that was a kind of cool
mystery that you know ultimately led to
you getting an exotic weapon 0.73 not
bad I haven't played PvP in a while
it'll only get better I promise
we got clever dragon what's the current
highest light level four hundred four
hundred yeah oh okay
oh look neurosis is here Dan mejor a
former GameSpot Fame if that's the thing
he says better matchmaking yeah that's a
good point but they've been trying to
work on matchmaking for like the longest
time circulate in-game looking for group
for raids yeah well okay so I'm torn
about that and I think I want chat to
kind of chime in on this one too because
so that's like a big pain point for you
know a good half of the players of
destiny if not more maybe is that they
can't do the raids without having a
group obviously right and there isn't
like a way for you to kind of have like
a group finder like you would with your
heroic strikes and whatnot yeah
but then there's the other part of it
we're like whoa the elitist in me is
like you know the raid is something that
is harder that you and I'm not trying to
exclude people but you know you you
definitely want to have a group of
people that you can play with that you
trust because what if you get into a
group with just like people that don't
want to listen don't have headsets like
can't figure it out
because like voice communication I feel
like in the raid is like pretty key
depending on oh yeah in in certain some
cases more than others
so what they can try to do is they can
try to maybe meet halfway so I've laid a
lot of Wow I don't know if you played a
lot of well but what Wow ended up doing
was they had tiers of the raid which
destiny kind of has already yeah sort of
but you can make like a raid light that
has a group finder or like one that you
can search for with other people and you
could get rewards but maybe the light
isn't as high as like the stuff you
would get in a normal version of the
rate that would be a good way to do it
so that people cuz you hear a lot of
people who just don't ever experience
yeah it's exactly and it's sort of like
that's a bummer because they are some of
the best parts about the game I mean for
me it's more that like on their website
on bungie.net they have like a browser
based like yeah yeah yeah said lfg yeah
yeah with G I would just like something
like that in the game basically like
like a system where yes I don't
necessarily want like a blind you know
match me yeah yeah you want something
more kind of like yeah but define
exactly they take them this stuff they
already have on their website and just
remember that direction in the game like
cut out like I feel like you immediately
you turn people off when you say hey you
got to go to our website if you want to
like try and like match up mean like
randos yes that's fair the same way it's
like hey if you want the store you got
to go to a website look at the green one
like I don't want to do that yeah this
is gonna go swimmingly I know it
I used to be able to shoot a hand cannon
those days are over anything it's a big
question you're gonna play on a PC or
ps4 I will probably play on ps4 Oh God
what about you I originally thought I'll
just take the ps4 all of my friends are
switching a PC
oh wow okay then cuz I was like well I
guess I'll just stick with the ps4 cuz
that's for real hard they're all like
yep going to PC if like ah shoot do I
have to go to PC now they're all leaving
me I mean basically it comes down to
like where'd you the majority of your
friends play right yes like the actual
answer but I think most of my friends
are on ps4 already so it's like I'm used
to them used to playing there so I'll
probably just play here I'm curious you
know like what type of ps4 pro support
or whatnot is is there going to be right
they haven't really talked about that
aspect of it you know like are you like
4k or like whatnot so that's what I'm
interested that's the that's a good
point
stick them no yeah I mean I have a
friend who never played the game just
got a ps4 recently finally finally
picked up the game he known like the $30
a bundle like with everything everything
yeah and I mean he's like he like loves
it he's funny he was like I take back
all the bad things I've ever said about
destiny this game is amazing yeah I mean
it's still for me personally one of the
best like field like shooting mechanics
type game like the feel the sound like
all of that is on point at like of all
the shooters I played so far I don't
think there's one that's been better
than destiny for me because like you
know you know when someone's shooting
like a hawk moon you know when someone's
shooting like a last word so I don't
know I think from that perspective sure
and then the question is how does that
feel on a mouse and keyboard yeah and
then like is a cross play I don't think
things gonna be like overwatch right
happy I feel like it oh I just suppress
myself for that to happen but there's
too much competitiveness in this game to
make that work or if you like specific
things mm-hmm well I know there's this
one
on Twitch that somehow already has like
a keyboard mouse setup for like his
either as Xbox or Playstation all that
kind of feels there's weird hacks you
can do with that but that you're still
restricted to the fact that the aiming
is designed for console so it has like
you know the acceleration yeah brand and
big aim assistance oh yeah so like
that's the kind of thing where you want
that to be different on a mouse and
keyboard mmm so just the yeah like the
way they handle that and then like how
that effects the gunplay is something
I'm kind of interested in so you're
gonna go PC then right I'm what you just
said although my although my friend who
just got it was a on ps4 man yeah he's
like hey I don't know if my PC can run
it so I might stick up ps4 and was like
dude like I I don't know to kick now
that's tough
you just have to get as many converts as
possible dang it I gotta take her to get
both and never play yeah that's no well
there are some people that do the whole
like they play on one console and then
all their friends like for like other
friends I start playing they're like oh
god I'm dead you know they're like just
play on xbox with us and then they
switch over and they have like two sets
of accounts like an Xbox one account and
a ps4 account which i think is insane I
had a friend who did that but that's
because he didn't own a ps4 when he
finally got one he just switched over
and I think he's touched it on stickam
Xbox on well that's fair
alright we're gonna switch back to ask
out cuz this maps too far for this game
kidding also because I'm scoping it up
with the hand gang
now that's interesting some brings up
the idea of uh like capture the flag
came in the hill big maps of vehicles
mm-hmm well their capture the flag is
like kind of is which one call it rift
right but that is something that always
kind of slightly perplexed me was
something I was not like Bungie did
amazing with Halo was they had just like
so many modes and customization for for
multiplayer that this game just doesn't
have and like I thought that's what made
halo really stand out and just some
degree still kind of stand out and so I
was really surprised that they never did
anything like that with this game now
wonder if they ever will oh just don't
run back in there
no I lost a punch fight t-rex arms uh
yeah I mean like more modes would be
cool that I mean like the funny thing is
do you remember when destiny first came
out they actually had vehicles as a
thing and then they do come out I do
remember that you're like that
turns out people don't like vehicle
combat I guess that's not battlefield
and like that has never come back into
the oh god yeah
oh I lived somehow I was like I'm dead
to another super this is great I mean I
would just like more robust bite you
know weird customization options I go I
can tweak the you know like a halo it's
like oh I can tweak the gravity and I
can tweak you know the amount of points
it takes and you know just like weird
stuff like that I like I like that kind
of stuff yes I have some of that but not
as much they finally added like custom
games and stuff yeah yeah definitely not
even close to the degree that halo was
nice grain yeah boys hard it's still
like set in this like world right that's
the thing is like where is in universe
yeah it's a little harder to justify it
I think I don't really like the
multiplayer doesn't really make that
much sense in the universe yeah yeah
they try ah we lost school they do try
steal that kill also a barely friend was
telling me this uh he's kind of into the
destiny lore that I guess like the whole
multiplayer conceit actually doesn't
even make that much sense like just
having multiple people because
apparently there's always supposed to be
like a handful of Guardians period mmm
is what he was saying according to the
lore yeah I mean I'm with you gray fox
it's it's not going to be easy for them
to have like raid matchmaking um I don't
know it's matching matchmaking with
randoms can be like good and bad like
for me personally I've had mostly good
experiences at least with lfg sites but
I've only done it a couple times I
haven't run into like that group where
you know there's like a one or two
people that are just kind of like jerks
or d-bags
they're like odd you know like you suck
we're kicking you yeah I've uh I think
that a friend who does do that oh my god
no he's not does he give him a chance a
fair chance
gives him a fair chance and he doesn't
he doesn't like verbally kick them out
just more of like okay I'm just gonna
kick
like just kind of like no like I feel
bad for that guy but you know he was
bringing down the group we gonna do I
don't know try to be a good community
yeah that's the thing is like I'm like I
could never try to like that holdout you
know I'm not that kind of person um I
also don't like playing for rent I like
I don't actively seek out random people
mmm the only time I've ever done it is
because I'm with a group of people who
then are like looking for one more
something yeah like shorter person yeah
we do that too sometimes but in but then
it becomes this thing of like do you
have Gjallarhorn cuz if you don't have
Gjallarhorn you can't join and yeah I
was that type of person that was it but
yeah uh I mean I don't know like I feel
like they've refined this game so much
I'm curious to see what they do to
change the feel in destiny to I don't
know like how much they want to change
it's like scary to think like just kind
of it's got that caught you like that
Cod feeling where it's like Cod doesn't
really break too much from what Cod
normally is because they're too afraid
like you know what I mean like they're
too afraid to break it because like they
know part of that formula works so well
and that's why people play it right so
like how do you what do they do to
destiny to make it still feel the same
for someone like me who poured like tons
of hours and you played a lot as well to
keep it still somewhat familiar but also
fresh exactly I feel like destiny my
current I'm kind of worried that destiny
too would be more impressive if taken
King didn't exist it's kind of my
feelings like when you compare destiny
to to say vanilla destiny you're like
whoa it's like this huge advancement but
when you take into account you know all
the expansions and like improvements
they've slowly made to make the game
better and refine it like you said now
it's like well it's not that dramatic of
a
of an upgrade mm-hmm that's at least I
mean that's just speculation of mine but
that's kind of my worry yeah
malice mage why are we pointing destiny
mainly because there's a new version of
iron banner mostly to hype for d2 and
just talk about our feelings about d2
and the fact that we are going to go see
destiny to next week should be pretty
cool pretty exciting I'm excited that's
excited I just want to like no I want to
know we're going to get a C right like
are we gonna be shown story they shown
multiplayer we're gonna get to see a hub
yeah new weapons new abilities like what
are we gonna get feel like it's gonna be
like one of those like first mission
things where it's like wow if I don't
get this guy
oh I stuck you though I feel like maybe
it'll just be like oh here look the
tower is messed up you got to take it
back and that's like the mission here
we're doing good job we're doing good I
miss them
I like that um Wow that thing we saw a
while ago the worst reddit person who is
saying that the the rage should be like
the the tower oh yeah that'd be sick
yeah that's that's such a good idea like
it's like actually the raid and you have
to like and then the final boss is in
the courtyard like you have to go up and
then yeah yeah I get Bungie hadn't
already been if that wasn't already the
plan if I was an employer a Bungie I saw
that I'd be like guys we got to change
things a completely change this because
that is amazing yeah it sounds pretty
cool actually
those who haven't seen the rate the
movie you should watch it yeah exactly
this poor judge guy they can call the
raid yeah the actual raid the raid come
on my super is wasting away do they not
have a full team Oh
gotcha no oh he got me she just switched
to smash and call the day what's your
favorite uh do you think okay so we saw
like an SMG right like that was a thing
yeah do you think there's gonna be a lot
of new weapon types just a few oh um I
think I left ah
see ya some jeans they got revolvers
they got pistols a cool wield Oh
halo - yeah a little dual wield action
man you think this do it I know it's
like one of those things from like a
Hello
I'm sure from a gameplay perspective and
it's better to have not do wielding but
I miss that they took dueling out of
Halo cuz I just like it's cool that was
like the thing you know like the one
thing that people wanted I feel like
yeah that they kept speculating on like
what if there's just like a exotic that
was like you know I do a wheelie do all
the exotic or some Call of Duty's done
that where most weapons are you know
standard weapons but then you'll pick up
a specific weapon that is dual wielding
so they could do it yeah that'd be
interesting
and they already got enough melee stuff
okay say you got swords you got axes
gigawatt hammers yeah but the axe you
couldn't actually that's true or not
it's not a that's just a pickup yeah
following line let's stick them um yeah
I'm trying to think of like what else is
left gotta be something we're nothing to
do but like lasers oh what a laser goes
up JM a laser gun yeah it's like the
Moonraker and goldeneye yeah exactly
yeah like a green energy beam hmm maybe
oh god what if they introduced alien
weapons cuz all the weapons you vex
mythoclast okay mo more more alien more
weird
Vartan lasers but Spartan laser yeah
zero says what if they just start um
like taking all the old Halo weapons and
lightly let's go is like the needler
that's so gay that you know what they're
kind of already there right like just go
the full way with it yeah shout out your
your thoughts and chat in terms of like
what weapons you'd like to see all that
guy's dead so this is more character
customization shaders are lame your
shaders are fine I don't think shares
are lame but I agree that more color
customization would be cool uh yeah and
more character customization I guess
they should be able to do it this time
around I would assume yeah although they
said that that's the one thing about
your character that would actually carry
over would be your characters like oh
god you don't want I'll show you my
character thanks for all team and master
the universe with like AI tattoos I just
made like a pretty blue lady with purple
hair that's good I have one I think
similar to that I feel like my warlock
my my friend he made a destiny character
we looked at her characters we literally
made the same character oh really so I'm
out pure accident
like Jay that looks like my character
that it was about to happen they didn't
have that many options oh good do you
think they'll bring back a character
voices member they had that and then
they like completely abandoned it no I
lost them I to work um wow that would
because I don't I'm gonna go he had oh
uh dad ahead like dialogue for every
race and every they like six different
voices like prolific voice actors I
remember will read like five lines of
dialogue five lines in the original game
and then for all the expansions they
just like didn't have them record any
more dialogue huh
and so it's like okay just gonna not do
this anymore it's fine they don't know I
don't feel like I need my character to
talk like man I don't know that was
always kind of weird like in the
cutscenes when like everyone else talks
on it oh yeah I got one always uh weird
when you did talk because that's true it
was so you you wouldn't talk and then
all of a sudden your character talked
for like a second you're like whoa I'm
talking that's weird
emblem customization dude dicks we want
more dicks and stuff they'll do that I
feel like they like wanting those
emblems as part of like their economy at
this point right uh I mean emblems are
like one of the ways for that emblems
and shaders are a way for them to be
like hey do this cool thing and you'll
get this cool begley so it's hard to
song and there's some rng to it yeah and
then yeah I don't know
that's uh I'm slowly getting better guys
I'll eventually hit 1kd
well this is interesting actual faction
wars pledge allegiance to one four
characters like that Cades of allah I
Cora yes well no well those are more
tied to or you mean like me bad guys no
no like um you know what are they called
like the new monarchy okay dead orbit
like you you can swap at any point what
if it's like no no you pick this one and
then they actually like what if that
plays in a PDP where it's like this
faction versus this faction and there
fighting I mean that sounds good to me
that sounds kinda interesting yeah later
fire bucket thanks for coming by hello
Corrine um up he left why did he leave
let me see if I can invite him dark zone
from the division that's an interesting
that's an interesting idea
oh yeah look at these zones in like PvE
zones I turn into PvP zones as long as
you can't glitch off like you could in
the dark what if I can kill people yeah
what if I can gank people and then steal
their exotics definitely that's so not
happening there's no way that would
happen I'm just gonna queue up I don't
think is enjoying uh sex 1 2 3 Griffin
says you all think does need to have a
paywall or do you think it'll be a good
game I'm not sure you mean by that
yeah uh maybe he thinks like will the
base game be good and like you don't
have to necessarily buy the DLC for it
to be good Oh like you don't have to buy
like the whole bundle or package
together so yeah I mean I feel the same
way I would hope that the base game is
like worth the $60 and then if you want
to you know buy the expansions that they
kind of like add to the game and they
don't necessarily you know make you feel
like oh I wish this was in the core game
right right but they haven't really done
that I think usually it's just like
here's another raid or here's like um
the trial of the elders you know prison
of elders or trials of Osiris I guess I
mean more it was that like the taken
King in terms of story and variety of
missions I found was more interesting
mmm that a lot of the base game so from
that perspective but I think I that was
like a refresh right yeah that was like
a rush that was like a destiny I mean
they they had like the whole refresh
with a where they actually like rework
the story a little bit yeah and the
nolan north took over for Peter Dinklage
yeah I've never gone through and redone
it but apparently they like reorder the
whole campaign oh really
yeah I didn't go back to do it you get
this one they added on extra like quest
uh like Westham whatever you call them
cross logs okay we're
like with taken King but they also retro
actively put made those available for
the original game story and they
actually apparently like kind of
reworked it so you've actually do things
in a slightly different order and it
actually also I've worked in all the
other expansions okay so they actually
like make decent effort to try and make
that stuff like more cohesive and
interesting yeah I always tried it I was
telling people like hey this if you're
gonna do it this is the time yeah I
think that's why my my friend who just
picked it up is probably having such a
good time it's good yeah I mean it's
like the good version of destiny yeah
it's like way hey you just spent 30
bucks on like a ton of content and are
playing up pretty good version of
destiny okay
sorry no yeah it's just yeah basically
it's like oh you got all the good stuff
that they figured out and you've paid
one nice love mom some yeah I mean the
only thing he really missed out on was
sort of like that in zeitgeist of like
the having like the fresh raid in the
moment but he doesn't care about that
kind of stuff so I think he got the he
went out on yeah that's fair you mean he
didn't want to farm for spin metal in
the rocket yard I did that I did that
everyone had to do that here at orbs I
think that was the one I farmed a lot oh
man that was kind of like I was like oh
this is like an MMO for anyone that
doesn't think that like this one thing
is like in it what is that I had during
a summer job hmm there was nothing to do
and I was like well I wish I was just at
home I could farm some spirit orbs and
destiny but I'm a PlayStation but I had
my Vita and I had a but you could like
oh yeah how garbage was that though so
it was pretty garbage but it was just
good enough that it was I could run
around and collect spirit orbs
that's pretty I couldn't I couldn't do
any actual like combat really mm-hmm but
I could just run around quick spirit
orbs so I would actually spend some time
at work on my Vita that's pretty much
actually it became a mobile game for you
pretty much the mobile companion app oh
that's another thing that needs to be in
the game oh no oh a companion app thing
or like yeah just like the gear stuff
cuz like they had the mobile app I guess
it'll always be mobile or website base
like that's any item manager and stuff
like that yeah I have a friend who
that's how he when he plays he has a
laptop that has that stuff open and
you'll just change it through there cuz
yes amber yep it is on a little mini
streak here
x-23 griffin says hopefully destiny -
we'll get to explore the cities and
forests and such or the main city yeah
what about environment yeah it's a good
yeah that's a good point I would I mean
we know there's going to be like another
earth environment for sure but yeah if
like the idea is that the last city is
getting attacked I want to actually like
wander around that yeah I would like
more of that stuff in like the hub right
like that was always something that
disappointed me about the hub lists it's
like oh you got these Gardens but I
wanted to see just like random shops and
people like just like a real environment
you know what I from I remember from the
first day destiny came out I everyone
always thought there's that giant door
yeah
Reserve would hang out too sometimes and
everyone was like oh one day we're gonna
open that door and review like a new
part of the tower you get to explore and
never did that I was a big Eren thing he
wanted that so bad for the longest time
I wonder if they were ever planning on
doing that that was never a thing
stay we're talking about different class
balances buff abilities for warlocks
warlocks aren't buffing up man
I think warlocks is I don't know I all
three of their I don't know you're a
hunter guy yourself mahant er yeah I
main Titan I for me it's tight and
warlock hunter I'm not a huge hunter fan
I only made a hunter because I started
getting bored and I needed to like play
something like it felt like you're
playing something different right yeah I
pointing like another class saying I
have tightened be more of a paladin this
time around a healer yeah some type of
like hybrid tanky healer that'd be
interesting that's their support class
I'll put down a will of light stand here
actually that'll be interesting I don't
they don't really have that right I mean
I guess bubble is in a way sort of like
that but not really right yeah someone's
bringing up the interesting point of
like make it more class base like over
overwatch more like oh why me maybe but
don't you feel like they would need way
more classes then maybe yeah that's the
thing
well if you really like flush up the
subclasses then that kind of is maybe
maybe but then see the problem with that
is like every class is subclass they're
all based on the same thing there's a
solar there's like an arc when there's a
void yeah you would have to change that
stuff up pretty dramatically I wonder if
what what would be your three other
elements at there are some water earth
oh I got 2.4 Katie alright there we go
um wind wind yeah there you go yeah
thanks everyone for watching on youtube
and twitch and chatting with us and
asking questions
we appreciate if you haven't followed or
subscribed do that so that you guys can
get informed when we go live we're going
to start going live more often and yeah
we're going to go down to this destiny
to event me and John Luke next week with
for their gameplay premiere we're gonna
both be getting some hands-on time with
that so look forward to next week we'll
probably have more thoughts on that but
yeah thank you guys for tuning in
it should be a fun time I'm looking
forward to it I know I want to say most
people are excited for it I think um
yeah I'd say so so hopefully that's the
case for chat too but ya know I'm
curious to see what subclasses there are
and I'm really curious if there's like
some fourth class of some sort that
would be like yeah because like you feel
like you're going to the sequel of a
game that like you got to have something
bigger than just subclasses I feel like
but right what would that even be though
yeah like that's the thing is what what
are they gonna do to justify the two in
the name right you're gonna put a two on
it it's got it you got to bring
something real new to the table yeah
other like yeah you know like new
stories fine but like I feel like
there's got to be something bigger than
just that that's like oh here's the big
difference maker and also because like
everyone we'll just level that character
right beyond
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna make the you know
that's how wow it goes it's like oh you
can become a demon hunter I want to be a
demon hunter and then like you know
that's that's how they do it right like
every now and then they'll just add that
extra new class into the game and then
you're like okay cool like that's what
I'm you're playing we're leveling or
like I'm gonna level that after I level
my main which is my Titan or whatever
yeah oh Jesus
Emperor Palpatine we
I must secure our heavy I messed that up
real bad I always I got that guy uh
horse up clap heads up heads up eyes all
right
I don't can it even pull that out God
mounts ad mounts like that aren't
sparrows I'm realizing sparrows are
already kind of mounts I want to ride
like a wolf you write a war okay what is
this wow yeah scope just go more MMO
with this one even more MMO because it
was supposed to be an MMO anyways and
then it wasn't right yeah just continue
that train okay I didn't kill I would
like to see more like a cone more
interesting like side quests stuff as
far as oh yeah so that's a that's a big
one yes we gonna rework the way they do
it yeah it's not just oh no it's not
even just that right so we I didn't even
think about this so you brought that up
so good on you for doing that
um so we're probably got some new
planets right that's that's got to be
safe go soon
I want to say they said that in like
somewhere mm-hmm and and with that what
should happen or the hope would be that
like the spaces are bigger and then not
only are you doing quests from like the
main hub world but you run into NPCs
that are on a planet so yes exactly just
like an MMO right like then then the
hope is that like as you're traversing
you're meeting more characters more NPCs
really yeah I want those those
environments to actually have more like
people and interactivity in apart from
like you know it kind of becomes this
typical grind of like well you go to the
tower you pick up your things and you
then you go down and then you you know
yeah you do your bounties and then
you're done
right and then that's kind of it
something a little more interesting than
that yeah I mean I think that's that's
that's a good start right there right
it's like okay
each of these world's going to have way
more stuff going on and like man what if
they put that more even more factions
than just like what are in the game now
because I'm just think I'm thinking so
Wow at this point right like there were
like little sub factions within those
areas it's like on that planet that were
like specific right so it's like okay
now I'm farming the I don't know
whatever alien race there is on Pluto or
whatever Jupiter and like that then
becomes like a thing that you that you
then farm even more of which would be
yeah oh I don't want to brown says I
believe they will move away from weapon
talents and instead use mods like in
Borderlands you think so
I feel like somewhere deep down if
destiny and Borderlands combined that's
like the ideal game right when I think
about like the things I like about
Borderlands and the things I like about
destiny I'm like hey just combine those
two I'd be a pretty good game you know
like Borderlands does have that open
areas with you know and pieces that you
find and like I think their quests are
more interesting than destiny but then
it's like you know I
yeah the way Destin feels with his guns
although borderlines skull pretty good
uh yeah but I mean like it's just like a
balance of because destiny is like such
a big world right oh no all right so it
says a weapon and armor trading I don't
know if I'll do that I really wish we
could trade me too I don't think they'll
do it I mean it just sometimes like it
hurts the worst when you're doing a raid
or something and okay so what if they
had limited trading like Diablo uh where
if you're in the raid you can only do
with the person you were partied up with
exact for an hour exactly but but but
you can't just trade willy-nilly so then
at least you can say like within your
group of friends who you're trying to
help make better like oh I don't really
use hand cannons but I know John we've
uses hand cannons this really good hand
cannon we did this I don't know strike
or raid together if you're really nice
if I could just give it to you instead
of like scrapping it there or I got this
raid armor that I already have that you
you were trying to get yeah exactly I
can give it to you I could see maybe
that happening so like some type of
limited trading not be nice actually but
then that also the counter to that or
the devil's advocate to that or like
maybe from bungees perspective is that
well then you're not going to do these
events as often as you do now because
then you're easily able to give each
other stuff then you're not going to
like you won't have the hook to keep
trying to get something right like like
for the longest time is like I keep
raiding right because I can't get the
raid helmet you know but I would argue
that it goes too far the other way where
you're like okay I'm rating too much to
try and get this helmet and yeah but I
want that helmet I know like that's the
things like if they just let me get the
helmet for my friend who got the helm at
that time yeah it's just so
disheartening when that happens and it
was a little different too because like
in WoW it was like 25 men / 40 raids
depending on when you played um and in
those 25 men raised what it would be
would be like here's a token that you
take to the town that is good for three
so cut like three classes that whoever
trades it in gets a piece of raid armor
but that's not going to happen
Destinee obviously so man I don't know
it's just basically we both wanted to be
more MMO pretty much right yeah it's I I
really do and center huh hmm leaves the
real question they're gonna have it on
PC how is that going to become a factor
in terms of people modding and cracking
the game well I think that since it's
probably going to be like an online-only
game right that you probably won't be
able to do anything to it is my guess
it'll probably be like a blizzard game
where you have to log into there like
Bungie to get to your account which then
pretty much gets you from being able to
like change the files however by having
it on PC I feel like if things weren't
already data mined it's definitely gonna
get datum oh yeah so we'll see all right
what's Charlie Brown guys say here yeah
so yeah division Trading was like Diablo
trading it was limited trading in the
sense that you could do it within your
group or your your squad they should do
that yeah I think they should at least
do that that would be the hope but you
never know we're going to try the old
gold hand cannon again well they kind of
got Mark Martin lemonis and YouTube chat
talking about just like fetch quests and
having to get all your quests from the
tower at least like it got better to the
point where you could turn in your
quests without having to go to the tower
whereas like in the way back in the day
you actually had to like go back every
time that was a pain in the butt so just
think about how your quality of life is
a lot better now than usually it works
where you pick up you only have to pick
of all your quest once a day so like it
just kind of became a routine we're like
you walk into destiny
you go to the tower first you pick up
your stuff then you head there do your
stuff and then you're kind of done like
you don't have to really have
yeah multiple times I got god be dead
right oh hello as I watch someone get
are plated someone else gets are
completing I don't think a hand caning
is the way to go here but whatever we'll
make it work
hopefully yeah can we can we say um a
little we know about what we're gonna be
playing ah I don't even know what we're
playing well I know that what system
we're playing it on oh I don't think so
okay we'll just we'll just keep that
alright hush hush or now since I don't
know what we're allowed to say other
than alright invite the day we're going
to be there and like you know pretty
much what's in that box is you got that
box see which I got it almost now and
the pin and the Panda world without
light that actually does back when the
you know the the original original
destiny script I got like leaked a while
ago they showed like all of the stuff I
got put on the cutting room floor one of
those things was guardians of dark
there's like darkness Oh like dark
guardians I wanted me to dark Guardian
so I wonder if like a world without
light implies like you can become a dark
Guardian that'd be sick
that'd be kind of neat so then I would
be going for dark shadow light the
shadow points
I need a level of shadow points cuz like
the the traveler is all jacked right in
that trailer
oh yeah like just like completely jacked
well that was like the whole like the
original I mean so a lot of that spin
kind of reworking stuff so it's he knows
the whole premise was that you'd have
the guardian of life but then it would
you'd have other guardians called like
dark Guardians that didn't follow the
traveler and kind of the idea was like
they were evil it was more just like a
different like faction kind of like idea
and they didn't believe in the traveler
was kind of what it was there's
apparently supposed to be this whole big
thing where I'm the speaker like betrays
you or something like there's a lot of
stuff plot that they ended up not doing
at all and they probably not saying that
net that won't necessarily be in the
game because they've changed so much of
like characters and stuff like that but
they're I could see them potentially
bringing some of that back yeah like
like the the robot the stranger you know
she was supposed to be like a dark
Guardian religion is the original idea
for that character before they change
her that could be interesting though
like what if it yeah what if it comes
like a horde Alliance thing where it's
like huh you know dark Guardian like
Guardian that'd be cool like that
actually be pretty neat yeah I'm down
for that
got it miss come back here
ah yam you were object says yeah the
traveler was supposed to evil yeah there
was supposed to be like some reveal
where the traveler was what wasn't that
the traveler was evil as I like well we
don't know very much about him right
yeah the the ID was like the the
traveler the whole reason all this bad
stuff happened to earth is because it
followed the traveler and the idea was
like and if the traveler is actually not
that great because it's kind of caused
all of our problems and a lot of people
like we're kind of like against the
traveler
I'm so dead
save me who knows how much of that stuff
Watchi it'll ever resize a little bad
all just hearsay and guesses oh yeah I
am theory crafting well not their craft
now but one can hope
Wow that killed nobody
stick them nice tuck one yeah uh so I
don't three subclasses for you when you
play you played hunter right which one
was your favorite
I mean I really like the I forget the
name of him the bow one avoid well I
guess Night Stalker yeah um I mean it
was great for PDE you know just like
being able to like string up enemies and
stuff yeah it wasn't really back right
for it was actually decent at one point
um the really good like PvP players what
they would do because nightshade used to
allow you to roll twice that thing was
pretty bro
right that was pretty broken I like that
one because I like the abilities a hat
plus uh sent like a bow is pretty cool
treaded I didn't like the gun the Golden
Gun
me holding guns that's never accurate
enough with it oh it's real pretty big
reticle dos your smaller one right yeah
I could see that as a starting thing I
felt a little like disappointed man I
picked I think I picked the bad one but
then I got the blade and I was like no
okay I'm either my choice it's like
pretty rad and that's useful the
invisibility yeah that's true
thank goodness well especially when
you're trying to exploit raids ah yes
that that is that is definitely true
xeric zero h 8x dropping the knowledge I
guess that I don't know we'll see hard
to say what will happen one can hope new
planets new great oh maybe any races new
races that'd be interesting your
character transfer is over but we got
cooler races that you could play as now
yeah all right I don't know why I'd want
to transfer my character over as far as
like well I mean well nostalgia is
knowledge it but like as far as like
even sentimental it it's all sentimental
attachment there was like no story
conceit for me to like care about my
character really okay did will it show
my character now yeah see look Mike I
looks like he man thanks Rob um mistakes
were made
yeah mistakes were made I really the
funny thing is I made another Titan and
I really thought I was going to delete
this one because I really just don't
like how it looks but then I couldn't
bring myself to do it because it was
like my first character in destiny I was
like fine I'll do is I'll female Titan
and then I always think about how well
also because it has all like you know
progression wise it has all like you
know my dead orbits like leveled up like
really high and my uh and my uh you know
all my rep is like super high so I was
like ha man I don't want to look like a
scrub and give up all my this isn't even
that high though but you know probably
gonna do like one more match ish um so
if you guys have any other thoughts or
questions fire them off in chat because
as Tana livestream hashtag HMD oh yes
that's true
that is what Danny would say hold mut
destiny hold my destiny is what that
stands for that's really what stands for
and we just pitched so much [ __ ] we
could make a trilogy
alright zero you mean John Luke will
make destiny three
that prequel where we actually know what
the traveler is and why we're doing
stuff first
you know the reasons we do what about
ships
let's talk ships here's Curt ships yeah
spaceships you mean other than just
having it other things we do other than
just a visual what could they possibly
make them more Bravo ship combat or I
there's not gonna I don't think she'll
combat no way it's something more than a
cosmetic I know if I want to ship combat
but I want something something else well
here's one it's not real it's like ship
related but not like in the way that you
want it to be um Oh God
so one of the biggest things people like
about warframe and not destiny is that
you can do like everything in your ship
yes or you can do a lot of things in
your ship and actually hang out in your
ship that would be enough that would be
enough for me so would we be able to do
that is the question
oh come on Pete one more time ah jump
the wheel there's my hands on it destiny
- at e3 this year I think they said yeah
I'm pretty sure I'm not sure how about
that one Oh Lord yes but I could be
thinking of anything else I mean it's
good the beta is out sometime right
before the game launches which is
September so you have to reasonably
assume that it's summer whenever that is
right um but ya know anything the thing
we're seeing is part of judges week I
think so yeah so presumably it'll be
playable in some form it'll probably be
three at e3 they're going to show
something at e3 I hope it's like some
type of like the fourth class or
something it's gotta be big right like
if they're doing gameplay yeah that's
the big you make a good point the game
comes out in September they have to
start showing stuff they'll soon exactly
maybe I'm gonna get that don't let him
have it
I'll help you quickly feel like this is
a mistake
where are they I super starting out with
that's a whiff - nope let's stick them
thank you so that's that's Dan in the
chat neurosis is dead yes he says I mean
now that I have free time this year at
e3 okay what does that mean what does
that mean
he's got free time so he's gonna
actually go check it out oh I guess so
I'm gonna wait in line for that
I'm not ain't got time to wait in line
yeah you mean got time for anything at
e3 well yeah now we don't actually I was
gonna say maybe we could go before it's
the show fitness but I ain't gonna be
that you don't have time for no but good
to see it next week so hit him in the
leg at the most maybe I'll end up doing
a bye what can call it go - no like a
post press conference thing yes like a
last year I ended up going with like
Robin Mike to Beck's box they had after
their press conference like who knows I
might end up going away Connor though oh
god if they need me
Oh going done guy who knows uh yeah you
never know
I mean maybe let's stop by the stage -
you ever know true oh yeah that's the
point yeah the old stage
oh yeah smash that guy come back and
grab a heavy no don't have you Dan says
can get there first in the morning with
the exhibitor badge that is true we
can't hide it like I'm not sure true but
we got a set up for the show
I don't know we I'm pretty sure me and
John Luke do not have time for that as
much as I would love to do that man
need to be like if anyone would it would
be like micro Callie yeah probably
although uneven no my dad he's like
helping host rain yeah Oh God I mean
Callie's gonna host a little bit as well
oh nice during some dais that's cool
yeah I didn't even know about that you
heard it here first from John Lee yep
hot scoop oh that's a bad time to do
that buddy
goop says he'll open up the hashtag
blamed a crew shirts yeah
oh there will be no none of that none of
that there are only ever 10 of those
printed and that's where it stands I was
my first week here I came in and you
guys were all like we all got our shirts
in the today like you and Danny and Mary
all like excitedly wearing these shirts
and I'm just like I have no I what's
going on yeah yeah I have yet to wear
that shirt I have it as like a prop um I
think it's weird to put on a shirt with
my own face on it how is that guy not
dead so this will be in the flood line
goober are you going to e3 this year I
think he's gone whoa what do you what do
you looking forward to seeing there goob
what are you hoping to play nothing
nothing one game cuz lines man what's
the one thing you're looking forward to
playing cuz that's all you'll get
probably destiny - oh God thank you all
I know that it's gonna be playable there
is probably destiny
and I know ecology was gonna be playable
yeah I'd say a Battlefront maybe gotta
front to you oh yes no battlefront is
actually gonna be viable yeah three
things three three things will be
playable god
ooop says gs stage on show for right um
the we got yeah yeah there's no get we
think there will be one yes i'm so
playing the bads well you come back here
we're winning but not because of me
i'm dan says he wore his at e3 last year
at the twitch booth
great it's okay nobody understands that
joke only a select few will understand
so that's okay
if anything they all ward and murder ali
that one night there's like a picture of
like six people with it on no murder i
like this year well we just gotta make
one right yeah we got to make a new one
yeah uh Dan was saying he's like I got
to retire the Twitter account and I was
like don't do that ma'am just wait
so he's confessing that one of them is
him she told me for the longest time no
one was supposed to know it was what
it's like it's a mystery could I reveal
that depends one who which wanted oh god
I'll play one more because I was awful
um that's how that's how it goes here
but uh like there's so many there's so
many games whaat III like mystery
Twitter handle mr. Twitter handles so
murder Ally's one of them I guess now
that Dan has been exposed I've exposed I
didn't I didn't realize it was a thing
tonight no I knew it was him there's
like Radisson 13th floor uh there's
there's like Hamdi wet and ham solo I
think he says he knows who owns them all
no but there's multiple no no there's
multiple people there's multiple people
that own different ones so maybe he does
know who owns each one but there's
different I know some people that like
know different ones but yeah that own
different ones but I'm not going to say
like I know I think I know who ham solo
is I don't know who I am do it is ham do
it if people don't know what I'm talking
about
we get catered sandwiches yep of which
ham duet was one of the ones you could
pick from but nobody actually likes him
duet so that would always be the one
that was left over and if you got
unlucky you had to eat ham do it um
trying to think what else is playable of
you three
everything I know is already out well we
can only speculate right yeah so it's
like shadow war may be playable yeah I
could see that one being playable what
about do you think anything more on God
of War this year they'll definitely show
it I don't know if it was I mean like
show game play last year yeah so you
think just like another it'll be like
the horizon zero dawn they just keep
showing you stuff and you don't actually
get to play it to like later maybe yeah
I don't know I have no idea how far they
are in that one cyberpunk
what if you know no they've already said
well they they've already confirmed
confirmed really I thought they're gonna
talk about it at least I feel like
they've they confirmed that they weren't
gonna really show anything this one I
could be wrong that's a bummer
I had the wrong gloves on the whole time
that's fine all right I lied about last
gaming the last game because this one is
for sure the last game but thank you
everybody for tuning in on YouTube and
twitch yeah
I'm Eric that's John Luke stop we are on
streams from time to time there's other
people here at the office that do some
fun live-streaming so you know hit that
follow hit that subscribe and make sure
you come back next week when we talk
about destiny too after we've seen it
neurosis saying do you think death
stranding I don't know I think we'll see
it again yeah they'll show up I don't
and here's her Te'o cookie but Ellis
that was the sickest when the stairway
he walked down
oh my yeah he the the timing of him
walking in the timing of the stairs
lighting up didn't match her yeah but
Rovio still it was good it's just like
oh that was like a big like middle
finger it was so good
oh man so good Sami X party man maybe
yeah all right good yeah I could see
that I want to know what Xbox is showing
they don't have scale down I think
they've already confirmed no halo six is
here oh really
I want to say they confirm that but okay
halo three anniversary
10th 10th anniversary halo they did it
with 1 & 2 it's fair but they wouldn't
do with 3 the way most popular halos I
don't dispute that it won't happen I
just like is that what you want they I
mean I'm just thinking like what would
they do I was you know what for 20 30
bucks I'll play a remastered version AoE
free cuz it's one of my favourite games
oh yeah I'm not necessarily saying
that's like the most exciting thing to
happen like it that's the biggest
announcement they had that'd be pretty
disappointing give you pretty sad yeah
no that would be really bad because they
have Scorpio so they got to have
something oh right
they gotta have something good so it
says they like your type full vids thank
you uh except we probably I either of us
know like that it's all Rio Rob Rob Rob
loves him some tiny flaw that wasn't I
wonder Rob the Titan which Titans best
for you one that's like this he's like
his most popular videos ever made here
really it's like one of them like one of
the most viewed video has ever done
that's crazy
mine is just gameplay so it's not that
mine is mortal combat fatality
compilation I think mine's the s all I
got I think mine site Resident Evil oh
yeah yeah I've had a couple good ones
with history of yeah the Elder Scrolls
one was the the biggest but then I think
Resident Evil beat it out although
apparently persona might beat that out
that's apparently one real hot oh yeah
Ryan was telling me that still doing
real well cut that house yeah that's a
good one though good job by you well
thank you if people haven't tuned that
tune into that one yet and you're into
persona or thinking about playing
persona 5 John Luke kind of did a cool
history of that kind of gets you all
ready for persona 5 in case you didn't
play the other games yeah check that out
check out just our stuff in general like
Mike Scott reboot you guys you and Jake
got isatis party we're done with that
though okay has been wrapped we want it
we want to eventually do a another
series in the vein of that but not right
now we need a break yeah so probably
nothing until after e3
although we have some ideals damn you
Palpatine fire stronger than Red Dead -
oh yeah read that - playable they don't
usually do stuff at e3 now the thing so
they'll go on their own schedule and
you'll see whatever they have when
they're ready for it
right they don't feel like they're
beholden to that oh this guy's battles
out segars no leather boob oh god
someone saying that apparently the
actress for quiet had been leaked by
Nicholson but then he deleted his tweets
for I guess for dest ranting that's
really that's that's us with zero saying
good you're saying how did we not hear
about that yeah sooo to me seems like
something we'd know about you know oh
don't you run for me Michelle Rodriguez
I will absolutely tell Rob that you love
this titanfall videos the Titan pod
Hooten for all guys got heavy alright
I'm first well how long will that last
by not long
do you PvP my free kill that PvP much
yeah
yes um guys got sex although it was very
much like got a little mindless for me
where it's like well I want to grind out
these bounties put on a podcast and yeah
place here put on a YouTube video in the
background is on them KH j sauces i have
a question i hope you'll answer me sure
let's do it
ask away hopefully we have the answer
yeah pickle says is anyone gonna play in
justice - uh yeah we'll make Joey play
yeah I'll probably playing it what I'll
play yeah yeah well what definitely play
some you definitely you are definitely
being on the story you told me like I
was like why Superman jail you're like
you didn't play in just this one I was
like no I mean I wasn't like it's like
the big thing in the world but I did I
played the original injustice and I do
remember the story for the most part I
wrote the basics
yeah I'm looking forward to that game
now uh apparently the comic like the
comic adaption of that story went on for
a really long time
oh really wicked oh yeah I heard it
really well allow her to do well or
something it went on several years after
the game oh okay yeah it was a pretty
interesting so I wonder if they're gonna
do that again I think they are I think
that was already um one of the comic
book writers already came out and said
like I'm doing it I don't know if it's
for injustice - but they're still doing
the comic that's for sure oh hello
HJ saws question was how often does free
weekends happen for games like overwatch
I don't really know
not that frequently but it does happen
from time time yeah like right now
they're trying to get people to play
heroes of the storm all right right so
that's definitely that's free right I'm
pretty sure right I'm not crazy for that
one right that is free yeah so if you
want uh here overwatch skins and whatnot
that's definitely the way to go
oh great Fox mentions last was - yeah
see that at e3 possibly possibly
although when they announced it last
year that was they made it kind of
pretty clear that that was like a teaser
that they were like just started working
on that game so if they show something
it won't be that far and you know think
so I don't think so I think that game
stole ways away okay
they've already said no Kingdom Hearts
maryam arts
ya figure so I can slap me in the face
if they actually show something there I
okay you know what that's not true
that's not fair
they usually show something but it's
like you don't you will you actually see
release date or anything like that think
they've actually shown anything at me
since I develop social I'll go on record
right now that I will let someone slap
me in the face if they actually show the
release date for Kingdom Hearts 3 and
that's how confident I am that they
won't I guess if that's confidence at
all
wow that side of that cheese yeah heavy
oh ok well that worked out I guess
alright I'm feeling pretty good about
this one John Luke yeah best around
alright don't kill me I'm still alive
for now
whoa that's a lot of thank you thank you
Michelle Rodriguez um yeah anyways
that's kind of been me and John Luke
spewing a lot of what we want so destiny
is actually doesn't you sorry any three
yeah it's like a twofer one but yeah
we're thankful to everyone I watched and
all that stuff and you know we don't
we're usually behind the scenes yeah
that's true you know see us too often
that often ah you got anything else
going on this week that you need to kind
of like nope uh wrap it up some prey
stuff but cool of it yeah um so stay
tuned for that stay tuned to you know
obviously the lobby which is tomorrow
yeah at 11:00 right on for that yeah we
got to prep for that soon and then also
our prey review should hopefully be up
soon two more probably just wrapped up
as you had mentioned and should probably
be working on that already
here's your shout out Michelle Rodriguez
thank you for tuning in thank you sir oh
and a pickle Rick and some of the others
that have been kind of saying what's up
hi Sean that's as many as I can get in
sign us out get us out of here I don't
see you thank you
you